hey 42 here the word addiction comes
from the Latin word for enslaved by and
rightly so millions of people are
enslaved by their fix
whether it be controlled substances food
alcohol or even the internet we all have
that one thing that we just can't live
without but why do we become addicted
and what can you do to cure it
addiction is a serious global concern
and in some countries addiction rates
especially to illicit drugs are growing
at an unprecedented rate in the United
States for example substance abuse is
one of the leading causes of death with
a substantial 10% of the American
population addicted to illicit drugs
however Iran has the world's highest
drug addiction rate there's a huge
heroin epidemic in the country whereas
the United Kingdom is the world's
largest abuser of alcohol and France is
too country most addicted to
prescription drugs for a long time
scientists believed that only alcohol
and powerful drugs could cause addiction
but using advanced neuroimaging
techniques it has recently become
apparent that a whole array of
pleasurable activities such as gambling
shopping sex video games the internet
and many others can also trigger strong
addictions also in the 1930s when
research on addiction first began it was
believed that addiction was caused by a
lack of willpower and it only affected
the weak-minded and morally flawed
individuals so instead of helping
addicts to overcome their addiction they
would often punish them instead
unsurprisingly this didn't work recently
the scientific consensus has changed
today addiction is recognized as a
chronic disease that actually changes
the structure and function
of the brain the more we exercise our
addiction and take pleasure from it the
more it takes over our brain and changes
it so that we crave that thing even more
in the future
addiction really is a vicious cycle
different addictions show different
symptoms for example a tobacco addiction
has slightly different symptoms to a
gambling addiction someone addicted to
tobacco or any other substance will
usually experience strong physiological
symptoms such as headaches nausea and
fatigue whereas people addicted to
activities such as gambling will
experience more mental symptoms such as
being overly secretive lying to their
friends and family and continuing to
gamble even when they can't afford to
however despite the difference in
symptoms what actually causes these
addictions is thought to be extremely
similar the brain registers all
pleasures in the same way no matter what
causes it whether it be substances drink
food or activities the set of chemical
processes in the brain that makes you
feel like pleasure are the same in all
cases it is caused by the release of
dopamine in the nucleus accumbens a
cluster of nerve cells underneath the
cerebral cortex this area of the brain
is so closely linked to pleasure that
neuroscientists call it the brains
pleasure Center the likelihood of us
getting addicted to a particular thing
all depends on how fast it increases the
dopamine levels in our brain for example
drinking coffee causes our nucleus
accumbens to release dopamine slowly
unsteadily so it's highly unlikely to
cause addiction although not impossible
whereas drugs such as nicotine meth
cocaine and heroin or cause a powerful
and very rapid release of dopamine in
our brain when this happens another part
of our brain called the hippocampus
which is responsible for forming
memories creates new mem
is of this rapid sense of satisfaction
creating an eternal link in our brains
between the drug and a feeling of
intense pleasure since our body likes to
feel pleasure another part of our brain
the amygdala creates a permanent
positive response to certain stimuli
related to our addiction such as the
smell of cigarette smoke so when the
addict smells this they will crave a
cigarette this is why regular smokers
find the smell of cigarette smoke
intensely pleasurable
whereas non-smokers find it unpleasant
but by far the most dangerous part of
addiction is how our brain builds up a
tolerance in nature dopamine is hard to
come by and requires a significant
effort to achieve whereas drugs and
other addictions provide us with a
shortcut drugs can provide our brain of
up to 10 times as much dopamine as
anything that can be found in nature our
brain hasn't yet developed to withstand
such an overload of dopamine release so
to protect our brain receptors from
becoming overloaded over time our brain
turns down the volume on our brain
receptors making them significantly less
receptive to future dopamine releases
this has a devastating effect because
the addict will now have to increase
their dosage to feel the same amount of
pleasure that they did the previous time
and so every time an addict indulges
their fix their next dosage will have to
be increased to achieve the same high
this is a vicious cycle I guess
exponentially worse until the body can't
take the dosage anymore and it breaks
down so what can you do to overcome
addiction firstly you need to
acknowledge that you actually have an
addiction many people are in denial
about their addiction or simply don't
realize but they actually have one
there's three simple questions you can
ask yourself to test for an addiction
if you answer yes to any of these fee
questions you may be addicted question
one do you use a substance or do
something that brings you pleasure a lot
more often than you did in the past
question two do you experience
withdrawal symptoms when you haven't
used the substance or engaged in that
activity for a while question three have
you ever lied to someone about your use
of the substance or the extent of your
behavior
okay so you've established you have an
addiction what do you do next well next
you establish why you want to quit write
down a list of all the reasons why you
should quit and look at it everyday for
example if you're addicted to smoking
you could write I will have healthier
lungs you now have a set of goals to
work towards next set a date that you
will quit for good you can set it in two
weeks or two months time but whatever
you do don't set it up tomorrow and tell
yourself tomorrow I quit forever I'm
going cold turkey because it's been
scientifically proven going cold turkey
doesn't work at least not the majority
of people hoard of research over the
years has demonstrated that only 3% of
people who go cold turkey actually quit
you should instead win your buddy off
your addiction slowly now you have a
goal and a set time to do it in next you
need to identify your triggers a trigger
is anything that makes you think of your
addiction and might cause you to relapse
for example if your addiction is alcohol
passing a certain bar may be a trigger
for you once you've identified your
triggers you need to eliminate them from
your life avoid them at all costs to
stop any unwanted temptation and finally
and possibly the most important step you
need to find something to replace your
action your addiction has become a big
part of your life up to now so once it's
gone from your life you may find it
difficult to fill the time and that's
dangerous because when you're bored
you're at the most risk of relapsing so
you need to find something to fill that
void try to start a project take up
outdoor sports or simply go for a walk
the more you get involved with a new
positive activity the more you will
forget about the thing that you use to
be addicted to thank to the view
subscribe for more thoughty2